[Music]
hi oh thank you so much for joining us
for the first view from the top of the
year Marcos hernan's the Leo we are
excited that you could help kick it off
kick it off for us during your twentieth
year reunion no less actually I believe
the class of 1999 is in the building can
you guys make some noise so we know okay
let's go garlic so I thought we could
start by taking a brisk walk down memory
lane I prepared a little flashback
Friday photo of you guys can we queue
that photo clear this is an early
MercadoLibre team shot circa 1999 what I
love about this one is as you guys can
see start-up founder Co fashio fashion
hasn't really evolved since they for
consistency ok we are going to jump
right in because we have three times as
much wisdom to extract today I want to
start by talking through your academic
and career journeys you each have very
unique paths that led you to Mercado
Libre and beyond Marcos we'll start with
you you have a background in finance and
economics with a degree from the Wharton
School but you also almost played
professional rugby so tell us what was
going on there you pass up the
opportunity to play for the national
team is it because you knew you were
destined for entrepreneurship no I think
it's probably because I knew I wasn't
good that good of a rugby player ok
Hernan you did brand management at
Procter & Gamble financial analysis at
the UN co-founded MercadoLibre
then started a VC firm what did you want
to be when you grew up and what was the
moment that you figured out ok this is
what I'm supposed to be doing I think I
always wanted to be an entrepreneur it
was something done I imagined
opening later in my life and I think
that being here at Stamford at that
particular moment in time
also having met Marcos and everything
accelerated that probably 20 years and
ended up happening right after
graduation could you tell us a story how
did you all meet when I met before Sam
for that day and we became friends here
at school I mean we're always with a
group of Latin Americans who was
discussing about the things that we
should be doing about the internet this
internet thing that was starting and
obviously no one was ever doing anything
at at some point in time we said that's
why don't we just go and do it
we're also arguing about soccer and I
should say as a token Brazilian here no
longer discuss that unfortunately
soleio you have the highest number of
Stanford degrees on this stage can you
tell us about the inspiration for moving
from the technical world to the world of
business management and entrepreneurship
yeah so I was really thinking about
finance through through before coming to
Stanford joining Stanford and after
Stanford the way I got to to
MercadoLibre was through casual meeting
with Marcos at Lehman Brothers of all
places three months after graduating
from from Stanford he was visiting he
was fundraising already and and we met
and I was convinced by by his passion
the passion that he had to build this
company I called him on three weeks
later I and my wife who's here moved
from New York to San Paolo to start the
business there and in San Paolo so today
we're gonna dig deep into themes of
entrepreneurship and adversity but first
I want to start by taking us back to
where it all began so it's the spring of
1999 Ricky Martin is an international
sensation the euro was just invented its
overall a really good year especially
because the idea for mercado libre was
just born now it's a huge success it was
worth almost 28 billion as of the last
my check this morning but can you take
us back to day zero
and how did you get from day 0 to day 1
what were some of the baby steps that
you took to execute while you were still
students on campus leading up to
graduation well first I spend a lot a
lot of time in the library and that's
where Stelio became suspicious because
he wasn't used to seeing me at the
library the second time he saw me at the
library said I think you're planning
sounds too something that's a true story
by the way
and so yeah I mean obviously took the
opportunity to to drive John Muse to the
airport as xi was just saying and and
was able to get some soft commitments to
starting the business then I convinced
Hernan to start work at 9:00 was going
to be the CEO of another startup and I
told him why don't you just do the
marketing plan for me I knew I think you
would have once I got him in he would
never leave so I had to convince him
some way or another and yeah so I've
tried to assemble the team and do as
much research and try to get as much
commitments to funding as possible ok
and it couldn't have been easy starting
a company as students I want to dive a
little bit deeper into some of the team
dynamics of starting a company with your
classmates I know many of us are in this
situation right now or at least
considering it and we're having very
very tough conversations so can you
please tell us how did you decide who
was going to be CEO what was that equity
split conversation like what were those
dynamics about tough question in our
case it was it was the first part which
I think is the most important parties
you need to get along very well I mean
and myself and Martine dos Santos who's
here
I mean who's there and I was also
working with us we always hang out
together and we had we had we spend a
lot of time together so so I knew that
it was going to work well so I think you
need to start a company obviously with
somebody who complements you but also
someone who you get along well with
and then the equity split etc there are
different kind of solutions in our case
I mean I started it and then I and I was
good to be CEO a different company I
convinced him to do the marketing plan
sir and then we agreed on a on an equity
package let's say you shouldn't do what
our competitors from Harvard did they
were ten guys and they split in 1/10 10%
each so each each one had 10% of the
company and it didn't work out very well
for them it's no it's more about those
Harvard competitors a little not part of
the story Hernan I was interesting
because if there's one thing that we
were not it was very innovative idea
because at the time we launched mercado
libre there were like 80 other companies
throughout Latin America more or less
following the same business model as you
know the difference in the case of Maria
was long-term vision assembling a great
team the kind of commitment that that
team had etcetera but not the idea per
se and in particularly was this other
team from Harvard that started right at
the same time this is a funny story
because we organized our launching
ceremony in Buenos Aires and just out of
coincidence those guys had reserved the
same place the following day or the day
before no remember how it was and they
were sure that we did that on purpose
but it was just a coincidence
and we started competing they ended up
racing initially more capital than we
did
so they had some advantage but their
focus was more on marketing or on trying
really to hit some initial milestones
and go public very soon
while ours was more around trying to
build the technology trying to bring
build organic engines for for growth and
ended up paying out well in particular
when at the time we started my career
was when everything was really colourful
then everything went into gray after the
the bubble burst
and that when when you started to see
the big big difference between the two
teams and a few years later we ended up
buying that company at a fraction of the
capital they had raced in the market so
Stanford Harvard there you go I want to
get your your thoughts on the Team
Dynamics because as MBAs we often hear
that we're to type a and you shouldn't
start a company with multiple MBA
co-founders because it'll be too intense
what was it like for you joining the
team and building a company with your
friends yeah no I think it was a great
experience and for me the fact that I
was in Brazil and I had a clear mandate
which was really to build the business
there was it gave me some leeway
obviously we we interacted a lot so
there's there's balance there between
having the chance to really hire my team
build my team but also work together
with with my friends so I want to stay
on our GSB experience a little bit
because I think it's so relevant to many
of us here stelae oh what specifically
in those two years really shaped you as
a business leader what did you
experience what did you learn yeah so I
typically when I speak to to students
say don't follow my example okay which
is good I mean at least it's something
that people should learn which is I was
very much focused on finance I came to
Stanford already with the background in
finance but not with the with the
knowledge with the theory and so I took
all finance classes some really PhD
level classes and the like and ended up
working my summer in finance and then
after school as well and don't do that
really please don't this is this is the
chance for you to experiment for you to
go outside what is your comfort zone to
try different classes really learn
skills that you don't have but I think
the most important thing is is building
relationships and and and that I did and
that's why we're here I guess telling
this
story Sileo just mentioned building
relationships and I know Dean told the
story of professor Jack McDonald really
helps in the beginning when you think
about the people who had your back while
you were here who were those champions
and how did you develop and cultivate
those relationships over time well
obviously for me that class from Jack
McDonald was very important I had used
my silver bullet for for his class in
those states you had to use your silver
bullet and you know I spent most of my
time here going to class I I really
enjoyed going to class but I didn't
spend that much time you know studying
for exams and things like that so I at
the library at the library so I really
enjoyed because Jack McDonald would
bring a amazing guess that's why I use
his silver bullet and so I would always
sit in the front in the front row and
and and we had once I got into the class
and it was early I always got in early
to get in the front row and and there
was a guy sitting in just in there in
the table and he told me and it was just
him and me for like two three minutes
and he said I'm Joe doe I just dressed
up like Warren Buffett today and I had
no idea who he was so I didn't
understand the joke either
and the guy was Warren Buffett okay and
I was I was I was looking for funding
for my company so so then eventually all
my classmates started to walk in I
realized everybody recognized the guy
and the class started it was a great
class and then after the classify told
Jack McDonald Jack you know I'm I want
to do a startup I'm looking for someone
to fund this this company and I spent
three minutes with Warren Buffett alone
in the class and I wasn't even able to
reach him you know I next time next time
someone like this comes over let me know
yeah I will attend your classes anyhow
you know I'm always there in the front
row and he said don't worry you know he
would have he wouldn't have invested
anyhow he doesn't invest in Latin
America but these guys they have lots of
investments in Latin America I will tell
this guy about you during lunch and I
will set you up to drive him to the
airport after class so that that
relationship would
McDonagh really worked out very well for
me that's amazing her none
what were your most salient GSB memories
of support and rejection those are two
incredibly common and useful experiences
for self growth but I don't think the
latter is often discussed so please
share with us in general it's an amazing
amazing experience for me was very
eye-opening in all senses in terms of
meeting these many people with such
great ambitions
really amazing and also for us it was
again at a very particular moment in
time we basically presented us to the
technology opportunity that was
happening here and made us realize but
nobody knew anything about the internet
so we were all starting in a level
playing field and that gave young
professionals with really lots of energy
and willingness to change the world to
start doing things in any other industry
would have been much more difficult I
think that's why when I said I want to
be an entrepreneur about 10 years 20
years from now it's because I thought
you need it first to build something and
that is not what we needed but what I
always regret from my days here is that
it was only a 24 hour day there were
many things to do all the opportunities
to be present with speakers we in
classes with amazing professors
discussing things with classmates and
you could not do all of them it's it's a
challenge so they all produce are
amazing and it's about what you don't do
and how you make the best decisions
based based on that and it's difficult I
think it's something that Dennis as
managers as business leaders we keep on
facing well what not to do I think that
that is what a regret thing in general
has been an amazing experience and
an incredible journey and to be here
sharing this way with some of our other
classmates and and current students is
also incredible I think it's yeah I was
stating earlier kind of a joke but I
remember that I was in a very similar
event with Steve Jobs I know it's just
the three of us here so you're devalue
does the Argentinian well when you talk
about that time that you were here at
GSB it seems like it was you know such
the momentous a momentous occasion and
the time to really jump into
entrepreneurship at least that's what it
seems but Markus you have this great
quote that says they got tired of
telling me that my idea was not going to
work oh yes how did you find the
tenacity to take that leap of faith
despite overwhelming voices at the time
telling you not to move back to Latin
America after the GSB and what advice
you have for us I'm looking at the MBA
tools right now who are gonna make
similar decisions many of which require
us to go against the grain
well everybody everyone here at the GSB
is all all of the Latin students I knew
and everybody said this is never going
to work in Latin America never in Latin
America someone is gonna buy a product
they haven't seen or attached to someone
they don't know
that's that because I thought this was
happening in in Germany in Japan and in
the US this type of business mode said
you know this is for this type of
culture see this is this won't work in
our culture and I was convinced it was
going to work partly because having been
a Latin American who studied in the u.s.
I realized how Latin Americans behave
when they're in Latin America but then
how they behave when they are here in a
system the board works well so I just
knew that we needed to create a system
that works well with clear rules and
regulations and I was convinced that
that didn't discourage me at all
actually I was a little bit naive
because I thought this is great
everybody thinks it's not gonna work
there won't be that much competition
which I ran said before I was a mistake
there was a lot of competition but I
would say as an advice I would certainly
try to take risks you know if you have a
view of something that that is a
contrarian ooh but it makes sense to you
just pursue it but then you need to be
very resilient and long-term focus I
mean if there's a lot of bumps down the
road and you need to you need to be very
resilient because it's very you know the
bumps can be can be very tough you need
to have a great team and that's what the
relationships are the GSB for for me and
for us we're amazing I mean we've had we
still have many gs beers working for us
for for over 20 20 years
so so you need a great team because it's
you cannot do it alone and and it's it's
also more fun if you have a great team
but you know try to be contrarian with a
view that you really believe in and just
take risks and hold on to it and you
could say that the contrarians
held that view because they were
thinking about the economic landscape of
the market at the time or what they
perceived were challenges today when we
look at Silicon Valley and other parts
of the world it's saturated with every
type of start-up under the Sun but when
you guys started in Latin America that
was not the case there wasn't really a
big culture of tech entrepreneurship VC
dollars were not flowing the way they
are flowing today so how did you
convince investors to give you money
back then how did you make decisions
without not too much data it was hard I
mean we we started with VCS and actually
investment banks invested in us which
was a big problem later on because after
the bubble burst we had some of them got
cold feet and they wanted to shut down
the company so we had to fight with our
shareholders not to shut down the
company we had to go to a to a
shareholder vote and we were pretty
close to losing that vote because given
that we had raised a lot of money and
unlike our competitors we hadn't spent
that money some of our shareholders said
let's shut down this company and take
the money out and it's gonna be the only
investment in which at least we will not
have lost the money so so yeah when you
have when you get investors that are not
used to risk
it's it's not it's not the best thing
but it's the only thing we could get
fortunately now we have funds like our
nuns that are funding lots of
entrepreneurs and really
entrepreneurship has taken off and
there's there are VCS there are many
organizations that help entrepreneurs so
it's a very different landscape today
than what it was 20 years ago well if we
fast forward you just celebrated 20
years of MercadoLibre success and during
that time you navigated and thrives to
through multiple crises both here in the
States and in Latin America even IP
owing during one of those crises and you
were the first Latin American company to
be listed on the Nasdaq that's
incredible
stelae Oh what had been the values that
you have held dear in the past two
decades that have enabled you to brace
the ups and downs of this time yeah so I
mentioned when I met Marcos at one time
at Lehman Brothers when I was convinced
that I wanted to join there was there
was passion in his eyes when I spoke to
it and then later I also saw that same
passion and I think there is a sense of
purpose and what we do you know we we
saw the technology was changing people's
lives and it was going to change
people's lives I think when Marcos was
saying this sort of contrarian view was
that there was going to be impact maybe
the people that said no were the people
that were just seeing things the way
they were they were back then and and we
were seeing things sort of beyond that
and and I think that sense of purpose
the technology can change people's lives
when we think of what we do was as an
e-commerce marketplace the number of
entrepreneurs actually that have built
businesses on top of our platform we're
now also going into into FinTech and I
think there's tremendous opportunity
with with financial services
democratizing financial services so
those those I think are values that have
kept us together and and having that
that long-term vision as well hernán you
were at mercado libre and then you left
to found Kozik ventures when you look
back at
last 20 years from GSB from your GSB
time to now what has been the single
most difficult part of that journey
difficult part I think going back to a
couple of instances in our Mercado Libre
days one was when we tried to close our
second round of financing which winded
up closing but we closed that one in May
2000 and the bubble burst in March 2000
so I remember the time we had like
probably ten term sheets or time
investors really interested in investing
in the company as days went by one
investor will drop out and another one
another one another one and we ended up
with one final investor but remember
organized a call away with us to discuss
the marketing plan of Uruguay which was
a very tiny operation in America at the
time and it's a weird wait they want to
do this and we went into the meeting
kind of hesitating what the heck we were
going to say and basically those
investor communicated they were they
were also dropping out so we were left
with with nothing somehow I don't know
it's one of those games that you played
20 times and probably you end up losing
most of them but but we turn it around I
think again in persistence and also some
help from the investors that were inside
the company at the time we ended up
closing that round but that was a very
tough time for for I remember that we
used to get in a room together and say
what the heck what can we do and then we
will walk out the room say hey guys
everything is fine
[Laughter]
this was terrible because also our
competitors were doing a lot of
marketing and they were everybody even
even our friends our competitors were
called Arimathea and even my friends
would say so how's the remedy doing and
we were like no our C's MercadoLibre it
was it was so and not I would look up
ourselves up in a room and we were like
ok let's release our anguish now between
us you know and then we would leave the
room and everything is good but it was
very close around it was very very tough
I think that was a tough time then what
Marcos described of that boding I think
was the only time the board ever voted
for something in her career so yeah
we're kind of sleeping with the enemy
who were happy that the company was
evolving on our own shareholders wanted
to shut it down I want to dig deeper
into the nuances of building a business
in Latin America we know now that
there's so much opportunity mercado
libre has proved that Kazakh ventures
has proved that proven that but we also
keep hearing about all of these
challenges perceived challenges which of
these challenges would you say our miss
that you're tired of hearing about and
which of those would you say truly these
are aspects in which the region is still
behind I mean I would say all the
stereotypes are true ok the challenges
are there no it's true I mean it's an
example it's tough it's very tough
infrastructure it's not as developed you
know regulations are backwards many
times regulators are not thinking for
the benefit of the most of the people
they're just trying to optimize for
themselves or so so it's very very very
few times you encounter you know an
environment which is very pro-business
and pro-growth etc which you know it's
it's part of the game so you need to
deal with that and at the end of the day
if you are able to deal with that the
opportunity is still just as big but you
need to you need to understand that it
environment is not necessarily a
pro-business environment and it changes
and it's very volatile so all of a
sudden then you have elections and a new
government comes in and it's great and
it lasts for a few years and then a
different government comes in and they
change everything I would say except for
Chile which is a country that has been
very stable and growing very very well
for many years the rest of Latin America
is is very volatile and it's it's
challenging to do business there
I'd say the flip side to that is that it
requires you to have a lot of patience a
lot of resilience because otherwise it
would be easy and probably a lot of
people would be doing the same so so for
us having to deal with all that
frustration of dealing with with
government with tax regimes with unions
with all the difficulties we have makes
it makes it harder it definitely seems
like it is a lot harder than building a
company here what do you think the
developed world can learn from startups
and entrepreneurship and emerging
markets
it's Ballou you know I think it has to
do with with with that that it's not you
know a lot of companies that go into
Latin America example they they go with
some ideas of how things work in their
home markets and and those aren't
necessarily the same there we say I like
to say that e-commerce for example is
extremely local you need to need to
integrate with with payment providers
from from each respective country even
for Mercado Libre which is in eighteen
countries in Latin America the fact that
that you integrate with Visa in Brazil
means nothing for for Visa and in
Argentina you need to to do something
specific in each of those markets
logistics is very is very local so so
the challenges are really not to just
bring a model that works in your home
market and and expect it to to work
locally I think that's true of all
emerging markets Hernan can we get your
opinion on this localization topic now
that you are on the other side as an
investor working with startups what
advantages does a local
combin splay er have in the market when
an international no big maybe Western
player comes in I'm thinking about
Amazon's aggressive attempts to enter
the region are there benefits unique to
the indigenous players in these parts
the world that's a central part of our
investment strategy in casick we only
invest in businesses where we think
there are some what we call local
friction points something like what
Stella was describing because of
payments or because of logistics or in
FinTech because of regulation we are
again we're talking about technology so
there are no absolute advantages so
everything it's very competitive but at
least if you are the local player and
you know how to operate logistics there
you know how to get the approval from
the central bank that gives you an edge
versus the outside competitor drama has
larger funds or economic capacity but
does not get that final point so well so
it's harder who develop that if you are
in the Bay Area or if you're in China or
in other part of the world it's much
easier to do it from from a local
perspective again you need to be great
at it and that your advantage by me or
disadvantage is that your global
competitor has better access to
financing or other things so we really
need to make sure you can overcompensate
for that I think clearly mercalli has
been an example of that and many of the
companies we invest in and try to follow
that same path not only to large
businesses but those busy where the fact
that you are local and that you are
operating from the local market gives
you an edge there markeson in your
experience what would you say is the
biggest mistake that an entrepreneur and
an emerging market can make
overspending early and not focusing on
building a great product what we've seen
a lot is he sent rapprochement at you
see a lot in developed markets where you
have a lot of access to funds
stories like the ones we're reading in
the newspapers now we work for - just to
say one or uber they've raised billions
and billions of of capital you know it's
it's very rare that you can raise that
much money in emerging markets so but at
some point in time there is a lot of
liquidity in emerging markets so people
raise a lot of money in those points in
those times and they try to recreate
that strategy of spending and eventually
we will figure out the business and
eventually we'll figure out the product
and and I've never seen one of those
stories succeed in the region I've seen
many and turned that tripura and we see
succeeding are the ones that are very
focused in the product in the team
obviously when the opportunity comes to
raise money or a thread you try to raise
as much as you can but then try to
administer that that capital well
because you know the stories of raising
a lot of money on funding deficits for
many many years
are very unlikely to succeed in the
merge in emerging markets the window the
funding window always ends up closing at
some at some point in time but now we
have so many more of those success
stories you know earlier we talked about
how the landscape wasn't there when you
guys first started now there is this
huge culture of tech entrepreneurship
and it's thriving in part due to the
work that you all have done Marco's
you're on the board of endeavor global
focusing on long-term economic growth by
working with entrepreneurs and her nan
Kazakh ventures mission is to work with
technology startups in Latin America for
those of us who are interested in
building entrepreneurial and
technologies ecosystems in other parts
of the world or even parts of the US
that have largely been ignored by the
innovation train what would you say are
the foundational things that you've
helped implement in Latin America that
we need to focus on to foster innovation
and impact in other parts of the world I
think having a success case is very
I mean I see what Marc O'Leary has done
for the region has been key because then
many other entrepreneurs can say hey
we're going to be the next mark O'Leary
and that that helps a lot so and you
know and so try to build from a success
story I think that is very very helpful
particularly if you are from a from a
region that is you know not associated
with you know with tech or with the
Entrepreneurship try to try to create I
think Israel has done that and now they
now have many many many success stories
but they started with one and then
another one first it was waste and then
you know etc but so try to start with
one success case and I'm built from
there I think that's I don't know I
think wait clearly the tech ecosystem in
Latin America has evolved a lot in our
early days there was nothing we just
took advantage of that small window when
investment bankers wanted to provide
some capital to startups but then after
that was a desert for many many years
and then it slowly but steadily
opportunities started to to appear
really successful cases that can inspire
the next generation of entrepreneurs is
very important I think that having a few
investors that can really help those
companies take off with some advice is
very very useful obviously you have to
have the underlying tailwind of
technology entering that market maybe
not at the most accelerated pace and
there was something I remember that used
to happen in our early days we're always
growing at a very fast rate but never
had 500 1000 percent per year and in the
initial days of our relationship with
with a way that became for time a
shareholder of of Mercalli they were
saying they were looking at the typical
charts and seen who a year one for Eva
year one from a collier a year to four
years and in those years we were growing
much faster they would say hey this is
what we can can do today because of
infrastructure because of internet
penetration but
we think that we're going to have a much
longer growth trajectory because up
until you know we reach the kind of
population penetration in population
that we want we will take us longer but
we will get there and I think that at
that time people did not buy that but
there was what ended up happening market
is still today it keeps on growing at
amazing rates and all the other
comparables Groove much faster initially
but then they plateau and that hasn't
happened so obviously you need to have
that underlying force that is driving
that ecosystem and then be patient
because what everything we said happened
maybe it happened a little later versus
what we we thought remember that not the
business plan we put together for our
second round of financing ended up
happening we we we we we surpassed that
big time about 25 years later need to
make sure that that again you focus on
the long run but again success cases
investors that can help you there
the market was mentioning regulation at
least regulation that doesn't kill you
it's important I would add one more
thing which is a culture of giving back
and it's not just money but but time I
think there's there is this need of you
know what did you do what happened in
your case can you tell us your story
and I think that's something that that
we've been we've been doing a lot of and
more people other success success
stories as well not in America
have been able to go back and tell their
story obviously in some cases also
financing these ventures which is great
we are going to wrap up with our
infamous lightning round that I warned
you about earlier we're gonna do a
special iteration I'm going to list a
couple of superlatives and you will
point to the person on your co-founding
team to whom it most applies you ready
this is the first time that you do a
panel right so how did you do this in
the past most times it's just like easy
this or that questions over here to give
you guys something special okay
least likely to be RJ Miller most likely
to schedule a call at 2:00 a.m. do you
agree most likely to know all the lyrics
to death by seat though none of us it
was something in Portuguese maybe it
would be me yeah that was a crowdsourced
one most likely to never miss a football
game watching your bling Oh watching I
used to like football a lot but not any
longer so I still do I do okay last one
you ready most likely to buy something
from eBay I think that's the perfect
answer making them
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you